- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website, or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape;
bipedal, naked large-brained. Lone the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Christina] Thank you so much. It's such
a pleasure to be here. I'm going to be
talking about some other genomes that
contribute to what makes us human. This
may look like a photograph of outer space,
but these pinpoints of light are not
stars. They're in fact the glowing genomes
of millions of bacterial cells on the
surface of human teeth. This is dental
plaque. The human body contains an
estimated 30 trillion human cells and by
the latest estimate, 40 trillion bacterial
cells. And so, if you add these two
numbers up together you will find that we
are more than 50% bacterial. 40 trillion
bacterial cells is an incredible number
and at an average length of just over one
micron, if you were to line them up, just
the ones in your own body alone, end to
end, they would actually wrap around the
entire Earth and span more than 20,000
miles. 40 trillion bacterial cells is
truly an astronomical number and even this
fails to capture the immensity of this
number because there are only about 300
billion stars in the Milky Way galaxy. And
so, the number of bacteria in and on your
body actually exceed the number of stars
in more than 100 galaxies. At this point
you may be wondering how you appear human
at all and the answer is that, although
numerous, these bacteria are also very
small; on average they're 1,000 times
smaller than a human cell. When you add
them all up together, they make up about
2% of your body weight or roughly 1.5
kilograms. That's a really interesting
number because that's about the same
weight as your brain and your liver. Some
have argued that we should start to think
of the microbiome as an additional organ
system. Most of these bacteria are
concentrated in the gut and specifically
in the distal colon. And in feces, they're
actually concentrated to an extraordinary
degree. There are over a 100 billion
viable bacterial cells per gram of feces.
And so, if you follow math through that
means with each trip to the toilet you
actually lose 20% of your total body
cells. But don't worry, you regenerate
them very quickly after your next meal. In
addition to the gut, a smaller but also
very important fraction of your microbiome
lives within your oral cavity and there
they inhabit the buccal mucosa, the
surface of the tongue, and the surfaces of
your teeth where they're called dental
plaque. Now, the oral microbiome actually
plays a very important role in the history
of microbiology because the first
undisputed description of bacteria comes
from a letter written by Antony van
Leeuwenhoek to the Royal Society of
London, approximately 300 years ago, in
which he described, "very many small
animals which moved themselves very
extravagantly within his dental plaque."
He drew many of these organisms and he
tried to count them but he eventually gave
up and he wrote, "the number of these
animals in the scurf of man's teeth are so
numerous that I believe they exceed the
number of men in a kingdom." Now, if
anything, this is a gross understatement
because we now know that there are nearly
as many bacteria on the surface of your
teeth as there are humans on Earth and
each day you swallow an average of 80
billion bacteria in your saliva. So in
addition to being numerous, these bacteria
also contain an immense diversity of
genes. On average, there are about a 150
times more genes in your microbiome than
in your human genome. This bacterial
genome is so large that it's often
referred to as your accessory genome and
in fact, you require these genes in order
to perform some of your most basic human
life functions. This has led some to
describe the relationship between humans
and their microbes as that of a super
organism like a colony of bees, many
independent organisms contributing
together, or more recently, as a
holobiont, an ecosystem so tightly
interdependent that it behaves as a single
organism like coral. Rather than just
being a leaf on the great tree of life, in
some ways humans are actually more like a
tree house; a home woven from many
permanent and transient microbial
inhabitants. Yet, we have only very
recently come to even notice this large
number of under explored, and mostly
nameless, microorganisms that inhabit the
human body. In fact, it was only in 2001
that Joshua Lederberg coined the term
"microbiome" in order to "...signify the
ecological community of commensal,
symbiotic, and pathogenic microorganisms
that literally share our body space and
have been all but ignored as determinants
of health and disease." This is rather
remarkable because these microbial
communities perform essential major
functions within their host bodies that
include various aspects of digestion;
vitamin production and drug metabolism;
education of the immune system; and
defense against pathogens. But the
microbiome can also be a source of
infectious agents for example, the oral
microbiome is the natural reservoir for
numerous respiratory opportunistic
pathogens that are responsible for
infections ranging from pneumonia to
meningitis. The oral and gut microbiomes
have been implicated in several chronic
inflammatory diseases including
cardiovascular disease where in a recent
study it was found that more than 80% of
diseased valve and arterial tissues
contain oral bacteria. So the microbiome
clearly plays a pivotal role in human
biology, and therefore, it is critical to
understand its evolution and changing
ecology through time. One way we can do
this is we can investigate the ancestral
human microbiome by directly measuring and
analyzing it from archaeological material.
Now ancient DNA studies have long focused
on the analysis of the bones and teeth.
And we've made major advancements studying
these tissues. And we've been able to, for
example, recover host and pathogen DNA and
reconstruct the entire genomes of extinct
animals, archaic humans, and even ancient
pathogens. But studying the microbiome has
been very challenging. The human body
decays rapidly after death. In some cases,
mummification can occur but in the vast
majority of instances, we are left with
only a skeleton. But there is one
microbiome that routinely persists after
death and that is something called dental
calculus. This is a...what it essentially
is is dental plaque that has spontaneously
calcified during life, you know this by
the name tartar which is what your dentist
calls it. It calcifies during life...in a
way it actually is the only part of your
body that fossilizes while you're still
alive and therefore, persists, like your
skeleton, long after death. This is just a
close-up image of dental calculus; you can
kind of see what it is. If you're
wondering what this looks like in a living
person, here's an image here. This is
calcified microbial matrix on the surface
of teeth. This particular example is from
a woman who died approximately 1,000 years
ago. We can take a...we can zoom in on
this particular tooth here, and here I've
just shown that same tooth now in
cross-section using scanning electron
microscopy. We can zoom in on this
calculus deposit that you can see on the
surface of the enamel; there it is right
there. We're going to zoom in, again, on
this part right here and one of the things
that's very clear immediately is that it
has structure, it has a layered structure.
That is because dental calculus forms
incrementally. Dental plaque undergoes
spontaneous calcification which kills the
microorganisms inside but also entombs
them. Then, another layer of dental plaque
forms and this process repeats and, over
time, it builds up layers like tree rings
or layers of an onion. What's really
significant about this is what it means is
that we have an ordered record of this
person's life history from the earliest
period, closest to the surface of the
teeth, to the latest period of their life
just before they died. This structure
never remodels and therefore, is a
remarkable record of this person's life
history. We can zoom in even further and
actually see the individual microbial
cells that have been calcified in situ. We
can also decalcify it and use stains like
gram stain to visualize these bacteria.
Remarkably, when you remove the mineral,
the bacteria do not disintegrate. And in
fact, you can see individual microbial
cells here. So, these are individual gram
positive bacteria, for example, here still
with cell wall intact. What to me was most
remarkable is we tried, kind of on a lark
we didn't think it would work, we decided
to use another stain, in this case Hooke's
dye which is very similar to dot B [sp] if
you've ever used that, it's a DNA dye, it
binds to double-stranded DNA. This is the
image we got after that which you saw in
the beginning. This is the only
archeological material that I know to
exist that has so much DNA inside that you
can actually see it under a microscope.
This property turns out to be pretty
remarkable for calculus. If we're going to
use by comparison, let's just sort of talk
a little about bone and dentin, those are
the tissues that are most commonly
studied. They actually have very little
DNA inside, even when a person is alive.
So, bone, for example, has fewer than
1,000 cells per milligram, it's almost
acellular. We have, typically in
archeological context, we recover very
little DNA; typically, less than a
nanogram of DNA per milligram that we
study. Even that is mostly environmental
bacteria that have invaded postmortem.
Here's just some data we've generated in
my own lab. We looked at four teeth from
different parts of the world, different
time periods, and we looked to see what
the endogenous content was of dentin. What
we find is that only a tiny fraction of
that DNA is actually human, most of it,
the vast majority, is postmortem
environmental bacteria that are
decomposing the teeth. On average, we get
something like 0.1 to 8% human DNA; so,
very very low amounts of endogenous DNA.
Calculus is completely different. First
off, it starts off with far more cells. On
average, it has more than 200 million
cells per milligram. In our lab we've
isolated in excess of 500 nanograms of DNA
per milligram we've studied. What's also
really remarkable is we have very low
contamination from environmental sources.
These are the same teeth, but now we've
analyzed the calculus from them and what
you can see is the endogenous content, the
oral microbiome per portion is much much
higher, it's on the order of 60 to 80%. We
can look then at pairs, again, of calculus
and dentin and we can see the amount of
DNA that we can recover, this is a
logarithmic scale, is on average about two
orders of magnitude higher; nearly 100
times more DNA in calculus than in dentin,
in some cases, 1,000 times higher. We
thought in the beginning this might be
just because it starts off with more DNA
so we decided to test this. We took a
tooth that was very diseased, it had a
massive carious lesion and also a giant
abscess, this would have had tons of
bacterial DNA, tons of bacteria at the
time this person died and we expected we
might see elevated levels of DNA from
these samples. In fact, we don't. We find
they're almost the same as what we see for
healthy dentin. That seems to imply that
there's something special about calculus
that facilitates DNA preservation. We can
then actually go in and say, "What do we
find in calculus? This is an amazing
structure, it's full of DNA, what sorts of
information can we learn from it?" We can
break it down into different categories
and we can say "Well, about 99% of it is
bacterial." That makes sense. We know this
is made of dental plaque. Dental plaque is
primarily a microbial matrix, but about 1%
is quite interesting. We have a little bit
more than a half a percent which is
eukaryotic, that's mostly host and
dietary. We also find a tiny bit archaea
and a little bit of virus. The virus is
actually bacteriophage which are viruses
that infect bacteria. We can also extract
proteins from dental calculus. We can also
classify them. What we find is about 80%
of the proteins are bacterial in origin
and about 20% are human. I'll come back to
that in just a few minutes. Let's focus on
the bacteria first. We've identified more
than 1,000 species, but the vast majority,
more than 85% of the sequences, bacterial
sequences, that we find actually belong to
100 highly abundant taxa and some of them
are very interesting. Here's just a
selection of some of the bacteria that
we've identified in dental calculus,
ancient dental calculus. I mentioned
earlier that the oral microbiome is a
major reservoir for opportunistic
infections. We find many of these bacteria
preserved in dental calculus. I want to
caution here that finding them does not
indicate this person had this disease
while they were alive. Carriage of these
organisms is quite widespread, even
asymptomatic carriage, but these bacteria
have the capacity to cause disease under
the right circumstances, for example, if
the host is immunocompromised. What's
really significant about this is it gives
us the opportunity to study the evolution
of these opportunistic pathogens because
they do not preserve in any other context
and some of them are very interesting. So,
for example, Streptococcus pneumoniae is a
causative agent of pneumonia.
Streptococcus pyogenes that's one of the
causes of strep throat. Haemophilus
influenzae causes respiratory infections
and Neisseria meningitides is a leading
cause of bacterial meningitis. Now, we
have a reliable source to study the
evolution of these opportunistic
pathogens. A couple others that we found
extremely interesting are these three, a
little bit lesser known. We have here
Porphyromonas gingivalis, Tannerella
forsythia, and Treponema denticola. We
have them at really high abundance and
this is potentially clinically significant
because these are the major causative
agents of periodontal disease today. We
investigated this a little further, we
wanted to know did our ancient samples
have unusually high abundances of these
three taxa. What we did is we compared it
to a reference set of healthy individuals
from the Human Microbiome Project. We
found that the frequency of these
organisms within healthy individuals are
vanishingly small. Very very few copies of
these bacteria are present in healthy
people, but our ancient individuals had
much higher frequencies of these bacteria.
This did make sense, however, because we'd
actually selected these individuals for
study because they showed osteological
evidence for periodontal disease. What was
interesting about this is we were able to
show that despite a century of intensive
efforts to prophylactically treat
periodontal disease and prevent it, we
still see the same organisms that are
causing it over a span of more than 1,000
years. Now, one of these organisms,
Tannerella forsythia, we actually found at
such high abundance that we were able to
reconstruct a full draft genome. We're now
investigating it to try to understand the
evolution of this pathogen through time.
In addition to the bacteria that are
present, I mentioned before that we do
find some really interesting other
material there. Tt turns out dental
calculus, like dental plaque, acts as a
kind of sink for all the other things that
you put into your mouth; including, host
biomolecules, as well as food. Talk really
quickly about the host. Early on we
noticed that we were seeing human DNA
within dental calculus, this was really
interesting to us. We just published a
study last month where using a capture
based approach, we were able to enrich for
human DNA and reconstruct full
mitochondrial genomes, in this case, from
a cemetery, Native American cemetery from
Illinois. This is potentially, actually,
quite impactful especially in North
America there are many tribes who do not
allow genetic analysis of skeletal remains
because it is a destructive process. If
dental calculus can serve as a surrogate,
it may be a way of conducting ancient
genetic analysis without disturbing the
actual skeletal remains themselves. We
also find a huge abundance of human
proteins within dental calculus; this is
where it gets extremely interesting. Most
of these proteins, I've color-coded them
by sort of what their function is, most of
these proteins are colored red and that's
because they are part of the innate immune
system. What's interesting about this is
that by having proteins we get an
additional level of information. We are
not only identifying that we have human
proteins, but many of these proteins are
specifically expressed in different cell
types. In this case, many of them are
specific to neutrophils. So we can
identify the source of these proteins as a
specific immune cell that's reacting to
dental calculus. So what we're actually
visualizing here is evidence of an active
infection at the time of death. In terms
of diet, it's long been known that
microfossils, plant microfossils and
animals microfossil, preserve within
dental calculus. So, all that little bits
of food that get stuck between your teeth,
they actually stick around for a really
long time and we can see them under the
microscope. What you're looking at here,
this is a little bit of connective tissue
from some sort of animal tissue this
person ate. This is a Phyta Life, it's a
little piece of plant glass. These two
here are actually intact starch granules.
This one, the morphology is consistent
with the plant tribe Tricaceae which
includes things like wheat and barley.
This one has characteristic structures of
the plant family Fabaceae which includes
things like peas and beans. We can also
extract DNA from this and get even higher
species level resolution. This particular
tooth came from a man who lived in Germany
about 1,000 years ago when in his teeth we
found evidence of sheep, pigs, cabbage,
and wheat. Therefore, conclusively
demonstrated the German diet has not
changed much in more than 900 years. We
can also isolate proteins from dental
calculus to investigate diet. One of the
most interesting ones that we have found
so far is one called Beta-lactoglobulin.
Beta-lactoglobulin is specific to milk and
as a result, we've now been able to test
more than 100 individuals and identify the
presence of dairy throughout Europe dating
back to at least the Bronze Age. We
published these results last year. We're
building on them now. Our goal in the next
phase of this project is to try to
understand the origins and spread of dairy
in the Middle East and Europe. What's also
amazing about proteins and using this
approach is that because it's sequence
based, there are sequence variants that
are species specific. We can actually
distinguish cattle milk, sheep milk, and
goat milk and have a very fine scale
resolution of how these dietary practices
changed. If you'll pardon my pun, I think
we've only scratched the surface of where
we can go with dental calculus analysis.
One of the most exciting things that I
find about it is that, is it's ubiquity.
So, dental calculus is found in all
living, in all known living populations
today and we find it ubiquitously in
skeletal assemblages from the past. It's
also found on Neandertal teeth and the
teeth of Ostropreozines, it's actually
quite abundant on chimpanzee teeth as
well. And I think by studying it, it can
provide a unique window, a lens through
which we can better begin to understand
the evolution of our ancient microbial
self. Thank you very much. I'd like to
thank these people.
♪ [music] ♪